he's become an object of derision
that's very dangerous for politicians
when you're deriding treated as a joke
character not taken seriously that I
don't know how you recover for that and
I I would say that all supporters of the
union and those who want to see Scotland
and England remain in the union that is
the United Kingdom I suspect there ought
to be crossing the figures that the
current first Minister remains first
Minister for the foreseeable future uh
because I think it's impossible for him
to deliver on the breakup of the United
Kingdom if Nicholas sturgeon couldn't do
it I see no way that he is going to be
able to do it either so at the moment he
is probably the best guarantor of the
continued Union between Scotland and and
England